um zu überprüfen wie sich am medikamente
oder chemikalien sind werden bislang
tierversuche durchgeführt und das
verpflichtend in deutschland sind es
alleine etwa 400.000 tiere pro jahr
kaninchen ratten mäuse aber auch hunde
und katzen denen beispielsweise
chemikalien in die augen geträufelt
werden um zu kontrollieren ob sie essen
sind ein forschungsteam aus den usa hat
jetzt eine software entwickelt die die
gefährlichkeit von chemischen stoffen
mindestens genauso gut einschätzen kann
wie tierversuche zum teil sogar noch
besser das ende der tierversuche klicks
und science fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes
heinz videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasste nicht herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
wir haben hierbei klicks um
science-fiction ja schon öfter darüber
berichtet dass künstliche intelligenz in
der lage ist die forschung in
verschiedenen bereichen zu
revolutionieren und die revolution geht
weiter krankheiten könnten schon bald
durch algorithmen diagnostiziert werden
genome kostengünstig sequenziert werden
und neue medikamente entwickelt werden
computer könnten für jeden einzelnen
patienten und jede einzelne patientin
individuell angepasste
medikamentencocktails finden statt einem
wirkstoff nach dem anderen zu testen
könnte intelligente software auf
grundlage der genomischen daten des
patienten oder der patientin die
literatur nach der perfekten
medikamentenkombination durchsuchen auf
einen schlag können so tausende von
kombinationen analysiert werden und dem
ärztin team vorgeschlagen werden genau
daran dürfte große tech firmen wie
facebook amazon apple google und
microsoft und genau auf dieser grundlage
hat jetzt ein forschungsteam aus den usa
eine computersimulation erstellt die in
der lage ist chemikalien nach ihrer
giftigkeit sehr genau auch
vorauszuberechnen notwendig dafür waren
jede menge maschinelle lerneinheiten mit
zahlreichen versuchs und
sicherheitsdaten um stoffe zu
analysieren benutzt das computerprogramm
viele verschiedene daten beispielsweise
ergebnisse aus bereits durchgeführten
laborexperimenten oder tierversuchen
daten zu der molekülstruktur der stoffe
und sonstiges wissen zu der möglichen
wirkung im menschlichen körper
das computerprogramm ist zudem in der
lage die zu untersuchenden chemikalien
mit ähnlichen strukturen zu vergleichen
bei denen die
bereits erforscht ist als grundlage für
seine berechnung standen der software
dann eine gigantische datenmenge zur
verfügung konkreten nämlich die daten zu
10.000 chemischen stoffen und 800.000
tierversuchen allesamt von der
europäischen chemikalienagentur echa
diese konnte die software dann nutzen um
die wahrscheinlichkeit einer möglichen
giftigen wirkung von bislang noch
unbekannten substanzen vorauszusagen
und das ergebnis ist beeindruckend denn
die ergebnisse der algorithmen sind
eindeutig eine gesundheitsschädigende
wirkung konnte die software zu 85 bis 95
prozent richtig einschätzen
tierversuche sind dagegen oft lange
nicht so eindeutig mit mehreren
testläufen kommen durchaus auch
unterschiedliche ergebnisse zustande die
wahrscheinlichkeit nämlich dass das
ergebnis eines tierversuchs im zweiten
anlauf dem ersten durchgang entspricht
liegt nämlich nur bei 78 bis 96 prozent
die europäische chemikalienagentur echa
jedenfalls ist solchen computer
basierten methoden zur
sicherheitsprüfung aufgeschossen schon
jetzt fordert die unternehmen auf diese
einzusetzen
doch die leitlinien dazu müssen in der
praxis auch umgesetzt werden und auch
die us umweltschutzbehörde ist schon
seit längerer zeit auf der suche nach
alternativen und hat eine strategie
entwickelt mit der verfahren gefördert
werden die ohne tierversuche auskommen
diese entwicklung könnten in zukunft
tatsächlich das leid von millionen
tieren verhindern
wie fühlt es sich an tiere zu töten
ein sehr wie soll ich sagen
interessantes video von meyle
draufklicken anschauen kommentieren und
meint natürlich abonnieren bis dann
bleib dran